ok kommen wir zum nächsten punkt das
widert mich wirklich extrem an ich
verstehe nicht passt in ein etwas
glauben zu kommen bald ein video ja und
zwar hat nicht mehr so viele leute
überlegt instagram hat wahrscheinlich
jeder von euch ich auch nicht mal kurz
ein als übernehmen mir da noch nicht
folgt was ich eigentlich nicht glauben
dann folgten ein spaß als wir können
folgen wenn ihr wollt habe ich überhaupt
nichts gegen aber ich will auch gar
nicht angefangen direkt mal mit dem
thema und wahrscheinlich auch schon
gelesen
es geht heute um instagram typen oder
arten von insidern die wirklich extrem
nervig sind und die mir richtig auf den
sack gehen und ich will gar nicht
eingeladen aber jetzt schon zum zweiten
mal gesagt los geht's wenn es euch
gefällt das noch nach oben da würd mich
sehr freuen schreiben kommentare meinung
und so weiter und macht welche okay wir
fangen logischerweise mit punkt eins an
und zwar ich weiß jetzt nicht ob das nur
bei mir so ist weil ich halt
youtube-videos fahre auf jeden fall
ich kann jetzt schon glauben also würde
ich halt keine youtube-user hätte ich
auf instagram vielleicht 500 follower
also ich mache zudem videos und die
kopie auf ein paar das erst jetzt kann
ich meine das jetzt nicht ich meine das
ganz entspannt auf jeden fall ist ja
auch ins tal und schon so wenn einem da
mehrere folgen dann sieht man nicht
unbedingt alles und kennt ihr diese
leute die euch fünf mal am tag folgen
ihr seht dass auch das öfter folgen nur
damit die halt davon ausgehen der sieht
dass er jetzt auf mein profil um mir
dann auch zu folgen was steht ihr also
leute die euch andauernd folgt und dann
wieder folgen nur damit ihr dem folgt
leute ohne scheiß ich sehe dass und wenn
ihr mir am tag fünf verfolgt und dann
nicht mehr folgt ich habe jetzt auch
nicht fünf millionen follower da ja okay
wir machen weiter mit punkt nummer zwei
und zwar sind das wirklich diese leute
die immer im falschen moment licon
folgen kommentieren oder sonst was das
wird ja immer oben so angezeigt wenn
also bei mir will das immer hier oben
angezeigt wenn jetzt wäre kommentiert
oder folgt oder mit einem foto markiert
oder so also immer wirklich zur falschen
zeit folgendes beispiel beschreibt dann
irgendeine klausur die ist auch echt
wichtig und ihr wisst ihr was nicht und
kann auf euer handy
jetzt nur keinen job aber ganz wichtige
situation ist irgendwas herauskriegen
oder so ist das durch scrollt runter und
genau in dem moment like irgendwas von
euch oder kommentiert irgendwas von euch
um ihr kommt dann auf instagram und
wechselt dann automatisch vom
installateur ich ne kennt ihr diese
moment wenn euch das passiert ich hasse
das ich hasse das so kasse dann rege ich
mich immer automatisch über diese person
auf die mir grad
irgendwie gefolgt hat oder sonst was
obwohl das ja eigentlich vorliebe ist ok
kommen wir zum dritten typ und zwar das
ist eigentlich eine wirklich nette geste
und so und ich finde es auch eigentlich
ganz cool aber kenne diese leute die
wirklich alles ohne scheiß alles ich
aber auch instagram 280 bilder oder so
alle durchleiten und komplett das ganze
viel oder wie das heißt ist dann voll
mit denen obwohl er da vielleicht auch
andere leute sehen wollen ist das denn
hier kann man nochmal abchecken so
versteht ihr ok typ noch vier und zwar
kennt ihr das wenn ihr ein foto bereitet
guckt also nach einer stunde drauf pokal
schon 300 kommentare habe ich eigentlich
jetzt nicht so normalerweise sind es
nicht so viele lässt die kommentare wer
ist das und vestas zwei leute die unter
deinem bild einen streit austragen und
sich wirklich übelst beleidigt ich denke
so könnt ihr das sich privatgelehrter
nehmt doch nicht mein foto warum macht
man das warum ich meine das sehen dann
auch natürlich andere leute ist doch
klar wie die streitet und dann
wahrscheinlich auch noch auf dem niveau
einer neunjährigen ok kommen wir zum
nächsten typ und zwar sind dass diese
wirklich übels like kann ich mein okay
ich finds auch grünen foto viele labors
doch dafür nicht alle zwei sekunden eine
hashtags ändern
nur damit dass zum beispiel unter
hashtag gelenkt wird und damit man halt
irgendwelche likes riecht von leuten aus
china oder sonst woher das ist doch
scheißegal und dann werden diese
heftigst alle zwei sekunden geändert und
wenn das foto eines vergleichs an läuft
man die gut warum nicht ok kommen wir
zum nächsten punkt das widert mich
wirklich extrem an ich verstehe nicht
was in einem kopf was in deinem kopf
folgen kann um so weit zu gehen um von
norbert zu bekommen ich meine das gibt
es auch mit irgendwelchen deutschen
youtuber zum beispiel baby oder so wie
es bei youtube ist keine art
unterschreibt irgendwer
ich habe die nummer von justin bieber
folge mir dann kriegst du sie auch dann
hat das wirklich 20.000 von aber dieses
profil und ich denke was ist mit der
menschheit durst das muss man doch
merken dass das niemals stimmen kann
darum folgt bei solchen seiten hast du
jemals zu einer seite gefolgt willst du
sag nein bitte sagen schreib in die
kommentare ja oder nein
nächster punkt oder nutzer kennt glaube
ich jeder von euch bei mir ist das auch
ab und zu war da irgendwelche fotos pull
me und folglich auch bei mir geht das
noch ne das ist vielleicht unter jedem
foto 5 6 7 8 9 10 kommentare vielleicht
auch manchmal 20 aber wenn ich dann
irgendwelche mega fayman leute mein
vater die bilder kugel zum beispiel
fragt mich nicht mehr da ist wirklich
kein kommentar wo steht ein hübsches
bild sondern voll auf eur like-for-like
40 90
nochmal ein verstehe ich bis heute nicht
warum man das macht kennt ihr diese
leute die nennen sich black erst
komplett und an deren name aber bleibt
wenig blackra1n das halt nicht black
aber generell wenn du es auch instagram
irgendwas mit black heißt ich will ich
auch nicht angreifen oder so aber denk
doch mal ein bisschen nach ist das nicht
voll kindisch ist nur meine meinung
müsst ihr nicht vertreten alles gut
müsst euch jetzt nicht unbedingt oder
soweit alex das gesagt hat aber ja okay
leute und zum schluss typen a 10 und
zwar ich mache ganz normalen cell viel
hat und finster ab und markiert
irgendwelche leute die ich überhaupt
nicht kenne darauf ich werde wirklich
jeden tag auch so 10 10 ps markiert von
personen nicht nur nie gesehen habt und
die macchia wirklich so viele menschen
darauf wie es nur geht da für mich
sowieso ich bin nicht auf dem foto drauf
das foto hat rein gar nichts mit mir zu
tun warum machst du mich dann okay leute
schreibt bei dem typ der euch am meisten
aufregt auf install amon in den
kommentare ich bin wirklich alles so ich
würde mich freuen die lokale durchlesen
sogar touristen wetter ist mir war da
auch nach oben da mal gucken viele
daumen nach oben drin sind an sonst würd
ich sagen wir sehen uns am nächsten
sonntag wieder instanz tempel war das
ein wenig vergessen nicht informationen
links geht's weiter mit meinem letzten
video das war ja da ging es um mädchen
und zocken checkt es auf jeden fall
mache mich freuen das war irgendwie ich
in der box oder so also schaut euch das
mal an
und ansonsten nehmen als dann am
nächsten sonntag habe ich schon sagte
brennan